well I don't think that's the issue
I mean competitiveness tends to take
care of itself actually the Chinese
currency is gonna have to rise they're
running a huge trade surpluses but it's
actually in their own interest to stop
doing the read right now they're piling
up you know huge quantities of of
dollars that are in very low interest
and this is a bizarre use of their of
their resource that there's still a very
poor country the real impact of China on
on us is is actually on resources and
environment the Chinese have become
major competitors for a limited supply
of oil and so here we are with $90 a
barrel oil and that's that that rather
than the competition from Chinese goods
is the problem for our economy and you
know and there's a certain tension which
I think that we're all going to drown
because of Chinese carbon dioxide if we
don't first die because of the the
mercury from the Chinese coal burning
power plants so now they're a huge
impact on the environment as are we but
now now there's another country that's
doing huge impacts on the environment
and this is a raises the urgency of
getting some kind of international
agreement to deal with